We are now ready to start
sequencing real spectra.
But before we do this,
we need to agree on how to score
a peptide against a spectrum.
After transforming both the peptide in
spectrum into peptide vector and
spectrum vector, it will be easy
because this peptide vector and
spectrum vector will have
the same dimension, and thus,
we can score a peptide against
spectrum as simply the dot product of
the peptide vector and the spectrum vector.
And therefore, the Peptide Sequencing
Problem can be defined as follows:
Given a spectral vector,
find a peptide vector
with a maximum score
against this spectral vector.
The input to this problem
is a spectral vector and
the output is an amino acid string Peptide
that maximizes the score between Peptide and
Spectrum among all possible peptides.
To solve this problem, we will
construct a directed acyclic graph for
a given spectral vector.
For a spectral vector <s_1, ..., s_m>,
we will construct a graph
on m+1 nodes,
with these nodes labeled as 0, 1, ...,  m.
And we will assign weight s_i to node i.
How will we construct
the edges in this graph?
We will connect the node i to the node j,
if j-i is equal to
the mass of an amino acid.
In our two alphabet of two amino acids
x and z these masses 4 and 5,
this will be the set of edges
corresponding to amino acid x,
and this will be the set of edges
corresponding to amino acid y.
And the score between Peptide and
Spectrum will be defined as simply
sum of scores or
weights of nodes in this path.
In this case it will be 22.
The conclusion from this
construction is that
every peptide corresponds
to a path from source to sink
in the constructed DAG, and the
score between Peptide and
Spectrum is simply the sum of scores
of the nodes this path visits.
And therefore it would just reframed the
Peptide Sequencing Problem as the problem
of finding a maximum weight path
in a node-weighted graph.
We already know how to find the maximum
paths in the edge-weighted graph,
and it will be a good exercise for
you to try to modify the algorithm
that we previously learned for
edge-weighted graphs into an algorithm
for node-weighted graphs.
We are now ready to attack
the problem of finding
an unknown peptide that
generated a given spectrum.
This is the spectrum that was
generated by a mass spectrometer from
an unknown peptide, and
our goal is to solve the reverse problem:
Given a spectrum, find what was
the peptide that generated this spectrum.
After we learned about spectral vectors, it
looks like the solution of this problem
will be easy.
Indeed, it may appear that
the only thing we need
to do is to simply find the De Novo
Reconstruction of the spectrum, or
to find the peptide with the highest
score against this spectrum.
Before, we of course, will transform
the spectrum into a spectral vector.
In this case,
the solution of this peptide sequencing
problem will generate this peptide that,
as it turns out, is incorrect.
The reason it is incorrect is that,
despite two decades of research,
scoring functions that reliably
assign the highest score
to the biologically correct
peptide remain unknown.
It looks like we've put
ourselves into a corner.
We learned how to sequence peptides as
the highest scoring peptide, but,
as it turns out, this highest-scoring
peptide is not biologically relevant.
However, imagine for a second that
you know the proteome of the species.
If you know the proteome,
what is the point of finding
the highest scoring peptide
among all peptides?
Shouldn't we instead find the highest
scoring peptide in the proteome?
And, it turns out that,
although the correct peptide may not
score highest among all peptides,
it typically scores highest among
all peptides in the proteome.
There is a small print here and this
small print says "If the resulting score is
sufficiently high", and we will talk more
about this important condition later, but
it looks like we reduced problem
of interpreting the spectrum to
peptide identification rather than peptide
sequencing, which is reconstructing
a peptide as the highest-scoring
peptide occurring in a proteome.
If you compare peptide sequencing
with peptide identification,
you will find something quite surprising.
And as we saw in Peptide Sequencing,
we defined the best scoring
peptide as simply the longest
path in the constructed DAG.
On the other hand,
in Peptide Identification,
we find the solution by simply finding the
highest-scoring peptide in the proteome.
Hopefully, these two solutions
will result in the same peptide,
but it is often not the case.
Interestingly, Peptide Sequencing is
not unlike Peptide Identification.
In the case when the proteome consists
of all possible peptides, let's say
in the case of peptides of length n,
it will be 20^n peptides.
What approach do you think is faster,
Peptide Identification or
Peptide Sequencing?
It looks like Peptide
Identification should be faster
because the size of the space we
have to explore is much smaller.
However, the reality is that peptide
sequencing algorithms are much faster,
even though their search
space is much larger.
The reason is that peptide sequencing
eliminates the time-consuming scan of
proteome by modeling the problem as
the longest path in the DAG problem.
However, since the scoring
function is imperfect,
peptide sequencing remains inaccurate.
State-of-the-art algorithms for
peptide sequencing only identify
30% of peptides correctly.